I have my first chemo tomorrow. I'm fasting today by tumor paid is more intense when I'm hungry.
Is there anything I can take from paid that won't mess up the effect of fasting? For chemo,
I be proven THC gummies other. Well, you can take a medication or you can take THC that won't
mess up your fasting. So if you can think of fasting as not having food so your cells are hungry,
okay? And you can think of it in a cartoon like that. So if you take any food in,
then you're breaking your fast and you're you're kind of feeding yourself. So they're not going
to be as hungry when you take the chemo. But if you're taking a medication, then that's just not
the case. Some people even say that you take your supplements while you're fasting. I think
you should just really try to make your hands or cells as hungry as possible. So also I am under
weight. So fasting makes me feel very weak. Is there anything I can have that won't mess with
the effects of fasting, a chemo, coconut oil, tea, coffee, other. Again, there's differences
opinion with that. I'd say coconut oil maybe, but coconut oil is a fat that's going to break down
into a fuel source. So I'd say no one of coconut oil. Many people on fasts will still drag tea without
any without any dairy product or anything like that. And it's a straight tea or straight black coffee.
And technically you're not breaking a fast by drinking black coffee or just tea herbal tea.
So I'd say yeah, if that makes you feel better using some herbal tea or some coffee without any
cream or anything and even even even a no dairy cream or you're probably just fine.